let's talk about this tour that you went
on okay
yes can i talk about that this is uh
you did a tour uh and i get some credit
here i think
your favorite band is tool that's right
and you did you announced it to our
comedians following
tool on tour the tour
and this was just a tour where you
followed your favorite band
tool and watched them and you went to
whatever city they were in and did
comedy there
totally self-serving yes yes that's 100
true and we announced that tour on your
show and be
and you do you get more than just a
little bit of credit you get a ton of
credit because when i came on the show
and i announced the tour uh the guitars
for the band adam jones
saw that interview and he reached out
and he gave us uh full access
to like go backstage backstage passes at
all the shows
floor seats at all the shows hanging out
we had dinner he came to see some
stand-up shows
so it was basically what you can sing
you used me
you used me yes to get close to your
favorite band
that's exactly right for what like two
months
while your lovely cute daughter we just
met
was it home alone uh well she might have
been alone but she was hiding
she was hiding for two straight months
probably set some kind of a record
[Laughter]